breaking an antique item that changed
the future of cinema defending the
legacy of someone iconic being a victim
of a near fatal car crash these are just
a few of the challenges the stars of
quentin tarantino's iconic filmography
have had to overcome while filming keep
watching to find out quentin tarantino's
2015 film the hateful eight shares a
number of similarities with his debut
feature reservoir dogs one major detail
both films share is that for the most
part they each take place in one
location reservoir dogs sees a group of
strangers confined to a warehouse while
the hateful eight places the characters
in a stagecoach lodge while one might
imagine that a movie taking place
indoors for the majority of its run time
would be relatively straightforward to
film that was absolutely not the case
for the hateful eight as revealed by the
hollywood reporter tarantino demanded an
authentic environment rather than
shooting the interior shots in a studio
the director instead chose to place his
cast in colorado's sub-zero temperatures
for 10 weeks starting in january once
inside the lodge the director would
reportedly keep the single room at a 35
degree temperature to keep the
performances and the shivering realistic
actor walton goggins revealed that it
was so cold the cast and crew would
squeeze themselves under the set lights
for warmth thankfully the grueling time
on set led the film's stars to bond and
ultimately look forward to the end
result samuel jackson mentioned to
collider we were miserable in the
environment you could see our breath but
the stuff that we were doing was amazing
set in post civil war wyoming the
hateful eight follows eight strangers
cooped up in a stagecoach lodge while
they wait for a blizzard to subside
among the strangers is bounty hunter
john the hangman ruth played by kurt
russell and his prisoner daisy dahmergu
played by jennifer jason lee
unfortunately the duo found themselves
in a scene with painful real-life
consequences at one point in the film
dahmer ghoul sits in the lodge and plays
a guitar but her moment of peace is
swiftly interrupted by roof snatching it
away and smashing it to bits right next
to her music time's over
if you pay attention to lee's reaction
in the scene you'll see a look of sheer
panic and she wasn't hamming it up for
the camera as russell came to find out
the guitar he smashed was a genuine
antique from the 19th century borrowed
from the martin guitar museum according
to the film sound mixer mark ulano
russell was supposed to grab the guitar
and wait for the scene to cut while crew
members exchanged the priceless
instrument for a double according to
business insider these details were not
adequately explained to the actor the
museum director was horrified at the
destruction of the piece and although he
was reimbursed for the damages he
declared that the company wouldn't be
loaning out their guitars to film sets
anymore in 2016 lee told billboard that
russell felt so bad about the mix-up he
almost cried when he found out
for anyone who's seen 1992's reservoir
dogs it's almost impossible to listen to
the steelers real hit stuck in the
middle with you without immediately
thinking of michael madsen's mr blonde
grooving to the beat while mutilating a
police officer although madsen nailed
the part of the psychopathic mr blonde
he initially never saw his character as
the villain instead he figured the
audience would appreciate him hurting a
cop in a movie where all the
protagonists were criminals that is
until he learned one particular detail
about the officer according to tarantino
during rehearsals the director himself
played the role of the tortured police
officer at one point while in character
he blurted out that he had a child
madsen who had recently had a son felt
immediate discomfort knowing his
character was supposed to torture a
father changed his entire perception of
the scene madsen said he was also
intimidated to shoot his deranged dance
and almost refused to do it while matson
admits that reservoir dogs was important
in launching his career he believes his
now iconic role as mr blonde ruined his
chances of showing his acting range in
the years to come he told the hollywood
reporter unfortunately it typecasted me
as a bad guy i would prefer to be a
leading man
pulp fiction star uma thurman was once
one of quentin tarantino's most frequent
collaborators the pair had such a
professional love for one another that
tarantino called thurman his muse in a
2004 interview with rolling stone while
tarantino was quick to gush about his
leading lady in public things weren't
exactly as they seemed behind the scenes
as it turns out during the filming of
kill bill tarantino put thurman in an
incredibly dicey situation which she
didn't speak about until 2018. in a
shocking interview with the new york
times thurman detailed a story about a
scene that saw her driving a convertible
an issue arose after thurman spoke to
one of the crew members who suggested
the car might be unsafe to drive she
told tarantino she wanted a stunt person
to do it she explained to the times
quentin came in my trailer and didn't
like to hear no he was furious thurman
ultimately cooperated but the scene
nearly cost her her life in footage of
the incident that she published on her
instagram thurman loses control of the
vehicle and smashes into a tree the
accident damaged both her neck and her
knees and led to a massive argument with
tarantino the duo settled their
differences years later with tarantino
finally giving thurman the footage to
share with the public for years leading
up to this dispute he'd had it covered
up by disgraced producer harvey
weinstein
after once upon a time in hollywood came
out in 2019 quentin tarantino's
long-anticipated ninth feature film was
met with immediate backlash due to the
depiction of martial arts legend bruce
lee on camera during one scene lee
played by mike moe boasts that he could
beat cash's clay in a fight leading brad
pitt's character cliff boof to
laughingly disagree an enraged lee
challenges booth to a fight which ends
with each man getting knocked down over
the course of two rounds before someone
else intervenes according to the los
angeles times bruce lee's family
considered his depiction in the film a
mockery interestingly enough if
tarantino had it his way that mockery
would have gotten much worse according
to a huffington post interview with
stunt coordinator robert alonso the
original script saw booth winning a
third round against lee which didn't sit
well with the cast and crew including
brad pitt alonzo explained that pid
voiced his discomfort with the scene
adding that it was actually thanks to
the actors insistence that tarantino
changed the outcome according to mo
tarantino didn't mean any disrespect by
lee's portrayal in fact mo confirmed
that the director was a big fan of lee's
work he elaborated that at moe's
audition the pair spoke about the
martial arts icon for a solid half hour
quentin tarantino's 2012 spaghetti
western django unchained was met with
widespread criticism after its release
critics blasted the flick for its
jarring depictions of slavery a few
years before the civil war countless
racial slurs and its abundant violence
the film depicts django a freed slave
played by jamie foxx and german bounty
hunter dr king schultz played by
christoph vaults as they travel through
the south hunting criminals ultimately
the pair's journey leads them to try to
rescue django's wife groom hilda played
by kerry washington from a plantation
where she's held captive in an interview
with indie wire washington revealed her
initial hesitation to participate in the
movie due to the brutal on-screen
torture her characters subject to she
explained i was scared about the places
i had to go emotionally and
psychologically as an artist thankfully
she and fox had previously worked
together in the biopic ray and the
actors were able to lean on one another
throughout the taxing shoot washington
even recalled telling her co-star if
this movie goes on for one week longer
i'm not going to survive it ultimately
washington persevered even snagging a
best actress award from bet however it
wasn't easy washington told indie wire
that at one point during filming her
parents and manager came to set to
support her and one of the first things
washington did after returning home was
call her therapist
kerry washington wasn't the only actor
who had difficulty filming django
unchained while tarantino who was born
in the south told npr that he considered
the film a cultural catharsis filming
was difficult for a number of the
a-listers involved among them was
leonardo dicaprio who played despicable
plantation owner calvin candy the actor
revealed how difficult he found
portraying the inhumane character in a
chat with the screen actors guild
foundation it was really tough it was
actually uh
took a a long time to adjust to he never
quite felt
comfortable but that's part of what we
do you know dicaprio elaborated that his
co-stars were supportive he acknowledged
that in particular jamie foxx offered up
his own encouragement whenever candy did
something horrific and while fox had a
somewhat gentle approach to soothing
dicaprio's nerves fellow co-star samuel
jackson had a much more blunt way of
supporting the actor fox told indy wire
that one day jackson outright told
dicaprio to get over it reportedly
jackson's words stuck with dicaprio to
the point where when he came back to set
the next day he was completely in
character
1997's jackie brown is quentin
tarantino's most subtle film while the
director is usually known for
over-the-top flashiness in his visuals
and dialogue jackie brown takes a
reserved approach for going experimental
camera work and choosing to tell a more
gentle human story the film's
protagonist is jackie brown played by
pam greer a flight attendant who
smuggles cash for her gun runner boss
played by samuel jackson once the police
catch her they demand she cooperate with
them however the plucky lead has a plan
to keep the cash for herself filming
such an understated tarantino film may
sound easier than partaking in one of
his more violent epics but that doesn't
mean there wasn't at least one
uncomfortable moment on set as greer
revealed to peopletv's couchsurfing one
scene of the crime flick sees her
character holding a gun to jackson's
nether regions however insurance
policies would not allow greer to use a
weapon during rehearsals greer told
cinema blend she had to use her own hand
instead unsurprisingly this led to some
awkward interactions between the actors
and some accidental grazing of jackson's
groin after these uncomfortable moments
passed greer assured her co-star that
she'd be a lot more confident when the
time came to use an actual weapon anyone
who has seen the film will know she
absolutely delivered on that front
the late great lawrence tourney was
already a hollywood staple by the time
he starred in reservoir dogs according
to the hollywood reporter turning earned
his acting stripes being typecast as a
villain usually portraying mafiosos and
thieves reportedly his off-camera
persona wasn't particularly warm either
as the actor's star power grew he became
increasingly more temperamental as
tarantino told the guardian when he cast
tourney as crime boss joe cabot in 1992
his first few weeks of shooting were
pure torture tarantino who's certainly
not renowned for his etiquette on set
went so far as to call tourney a
complete lunatic when filming for
reservoir dogs began the director opted
to shoot tourney's scenes in the first
week after a stressful week of filming
the actor and director's conflict came
to a violent head tarantino explained by
the end of the week everybody on set
hated tourney it wasn't just me and in
the last 20 minutes of the first week we
had a blowout and got into a fistfight i
fired him and the whole crew burst into
applause although the thin newbie
director thought that getting rid of
tourney would ruin his chances at a big
break in hollywood he fortunately had
the movie's biggest star on his side
harvey keitel assured the studio that
everything would turn out fine and the
rest is history uma thurman and john
travolta's dance scene in pulp fiction
remains one of the most iconic moments
in 90 cinema as explained by the daily
beast the scene was inspired by jean-luc
goddard's 1964 classic bond depart
reportedly tarantino has always been
inspired by the way goddard incorporated
music and dance into his films most of
the scene was improvised and travolta
didn't seem to have many issues with it
but the same can't be said for thurman
despite her character's on-screen
enthusiasm now i want to dance i want to
win
i want that trophy
so that's good thurman told variety i
was more afraid of the dancing than
almost anything because it was exactly
to my total insecurity thurman credited
her youth and lanky build as the
culprits behind her timothy thankfully
she added once the dancing actually
began she adored the experience in a
funny and heartfelt moment at the 2022
academy awards thurman and travolta took
to the stage alongside samuel l jackson
to celebrate the film's 28th anniversary
the two actors briefly recreated their
legendary dance with thurman quipping
maybe later we'll have a five dollar
milkshake
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
quentin tarantino films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one